if we look back through time
there's always been this desire to get a
higher
picture
we continued to go higher and higher to
get a better and better picture to
understand what's going on
i'm keith massback
i've been working in the remote sensing
field for over 30 years
today i'm going to share with you just a
few tips and tricks on how to look at
satellite imagery the coordinates are in
the description if you want to follow
along
so the first thing i'd say is that you
never want to look at just one image you
want to understand
context and you want to understand a
place over time
because that's really where you're going
to start to be able to pull some real
observations the benefit of looking at
some place over time
is you're being able to see patterns
you're being able to see progression
why don't we look at some examples in
nature one rule of thumb in the imagery
analysis business is
mother nature doesn't make a lot of
straight lines
so your eyes an imagery analyst
immediately goes to anything that looks
perfectly straight another example
is deforestation again that's man-made
activity that comes
really really clear on remote sensing
especially from space
man tends to cut things in very clear
patterns so you see
sort of football field size pieces
disappear at a time
it's very easy to see despite whatever a
country
or a region or a company might be saying
they're doing it's pretty easy to call
them out
so one case i might point to is what's
going on
in the arctic and the retreat of
glaciers you can start to see how
they're depositing
sediment and how the sediment is being
increasingly exposed to the sun instead
of the very white ice reflecting the
sun's rays that sediment is actually
collecting heat
and contributing in turn to a faster
retreat of those glaciers next let's
turn to man-made structures
man-made activity that's certainly
important in my background is looking at
military activity
military people tend to like order they
like to do things
repeatedly during the cold war
we would watch the soviets rigidly
adhere to doctrine
they would always assemble their forces
in the same way and in fact today
even the russians still tend to do that
we're seeing very similar patterns to
what we saw when they
invaded crimea several years ago their
signature pieces of equipment
their signature activity the way they
rail load
and move their forces the way they're
parked
the way they're aligned these patterns
are very easy to spot
another sort of sad example of being
able to use remote sensing in a very
powerful way
was in darfur while the government was
claiming that nothing was going on they
were very effectively keeping the press
out of the country
but amnesty international and other
organizations were able to bear witness
from above so again through this idea of
looking at
images over time non-governmental
organizations and governments were able
to
look from above and see wholesale
that villages were raised and burned and
that was clear indication
that a genocide was underway
an interesting enigma for national
security for human rights
is taking a look at korea when we get a
defector
who comes across and wants to talk about
the re-education
camps we can show them images from space
and they can share with us
what are they seeing how is the camp
laid out what happens where
and once we can understand that from
someone who's been there that allows us
to understand that pattern and then we
can look in other parts of the country
and identify unfortunately the spread of
these facilities
let's talk a little bit about how we can
use remote sensing to understand the
activity of individuals
now when we're talking about looking at
the earth from space
we're not looking at individual people
we can see the impact of
lots of people over time something like
burning man
is absolutely easy to spot from space it
has a very clear pattern
it's replicated every year and you can
actually watch
over time how burning man has grown and
changed from space
whether you're looking out the window of
an airplane or you're looking at a
satellite image
try to look at it in a different way try
to look at patterns you might not have
noticed before
look for what you don't see is there
something missing that you would expect
to see there
just try and look with a different eye
and i think you'll be pretty surprised